[Music]
so since the program was published the
political situation in this country has
changed dramatically Forrest Johnson has
become Prime Minister Parliament has
been probed and some of the Conservative
Party's most influential members have
been expelled one thing we can be sure
that is the Britain or the UK is in
uncharted territory not simply on the
issue of whether and how we leave the
European Union but also on the state of
our politics and potentially radical
realignments that are in the air so this
debate is going to focus on how we
navigate our uncertain future and to
help us as we embark upon this journey
we have a stellar panel we have Natalie
Bennett former leader of the Green Party
will be known to many of you here
because she's been enthusiastic taking
part in these debates Owen Smith who's
been a Labour MP since 2010 challenged
Jeremy Corbyn for the name of leadership
in 2016 and Claire Fox a libertarian
speaker and writer new now sits as the
brexit Party MP so good ask you Claire
you can start question where is Britain
heading so I um it's tied up with where
I'm heading so I just wanted to say
something about myself I'm a left lever
I was the director of the academy of
ideas and the Academy where ideas runs a
big festival called a battle of ideas
festival similar to this festival at the
Barbican every year and I never ever
wanted to be an elected politician I had
no aspirations to be but I think that
when I think about where Britain is
heading it's I think a different
landscape a bit like my own personal
landscape because leave voters take all
shapes and sizes and I think that there
is a danger that we have caricatured
them and that we underestimate what will
happen if the brexit vote is not
delivered I wanted
to also say that it was a very exciting
time in 2016 when people voted in the
European referendum it was a very
political time I'd been worried about
youth a path II before that and then
suddenly everybody was discussing
politics really came to life people
voted in good faith and in huge numbers
and any concern we had about the
electoral system not being taken
seriously was overturned by that and
they'd been exacted as leaving the EU as
was told by the people then I think that
that would have been a very positive me
but I think then what's happened in the
last three and a half years leaves me
fearful about the state of democracy
because not only has the vote not
occurred but also and at the moment it's
really intensified anyone in voted leave
is treated with utter contempt
they've been core a cyst and fascists
the rise of the far right as though the
1930's are upon us
people in professions have to be secret
beretta tears can't come out and admit
that they voted with the largest side in
a referendum I think that demonization
of lis voters means that where we are
now is very serious of where we're going
I didn't agree with the pierogi of
Parliament but I do think that
democracies on the line and on the night
the Parliament was probed
parliamentarians and MPs held upside and
saying that they'd been silenced I did
laughs they haven't shut up for three
and a half years and what they've been
saying for those three and a half years
is we're not going to listen to the
public and we're going to do whatever it
takes whatever it takes in order to
actually undermine what the public
requested and demanded and their
authority is based on the the will of
ordinary voters in the electorate and I
fear that ignoring that puts universal
franchise the whole of democracy it
questions every institution and it puts
us in a very interesting but dangerous
place not because of brexit but because
of the failure to deliver brexit loads
of great questions to discuss so I look
forward to engaging with my fellow panel
[Applause]
Thank You Sean well it's a good start to
a debate that I disagree with just about
every word that Claire has just said I
think anybody who says they know where
we're heading right now is there is a
liar and a scoundrel but I do think we
can say that we are collectively going
through what looks to me to be a bit of
a midlife crisis and if you doubt that
just consider the facts of the last few
days in our extraordinary topsy-turvy
politics and the labor parties in
Brighton will I'll be going later in the
week marching against ourselves again on
brexit we dusted off the ice pick to try
and doing Tom Watson earlier in the week
and succeeded in stabbing it squarely in
our own collective foot the liberal left
has a new hero and he's not in the
Labour Party's Dominic grieve a bloke
who wears three-piece tweed suits and
who only ever went on one protest march
until recently that was a lie this is
absolutely true as he told me when we
marched together for the people's vote
it was in favor of getting rid of the
ban on fox hunting jo Swinson is making
Lazarus look like a sort of crap entry
into Britain's Got Talent
with her Renaissance of the Liberal
Democrat Party and we've got a prime
minister and a leader of the House of
Commons who are more memes than men who
don't even take themselves seriously it
seems when talking about politics so
that's the you know just a few facts
that illustrate what a extraordinary
time we live in but to be serious
for a moment I do think there is a way
in which you can see the underpinnings
of this extraordinary time when
reflecting about this and knowing that
Claire was on the panel I I turned to
another lapsed communist formally of
this parish Eric Hobsbawm who said in
writing about the age of extremes not
the current age of extremes that we live
in but an earlier age of extremes that
it was a period that reveal
the innate floor in liberal democracy
and that he said was its susceptibility
to the virus of nationalism
ethno-nationalism nativism the support
of our people over the others and I
think that underpins much of the crisis
we have in our country today both on the
left and on the right and I think it's
the biggest thing that we need to try
and engage in and with to resolve it
I think brexit is in many respects a
function and a product of that rise of
nativism I think the talk of sovereignty
and the importance of will and instinct
and technocracy over rationale and over
reason are all echoes of an earlier age
Claire you know Lampoon's the notion
that we're we're seeing some of those or
hearing some of those echoes of the
1930s in our modern politics I don't
think that's I don't think that's
something to be dismissed at all I think
when we have a prime minister who talks
about pickaninnies and people with
watermelon smiles phrases that you can't
imagine being even on the fringes of the
Tory party other than the lips of Enoch
Powell 10 20 30 years ago but now coming
out of the mouth of the man who is the
prime minister of our country I think
that speaks to a very dark age that we
are living through and when we have a
period in which the Prime Minister can
seemingly prorogue Parliament with
impunity abandon parliament in order to
stifle debate albeit only for a short
period ever of a few days but with very
little public disquiet indeed if you
look at some of the polls in certain
parts of the electorate significant
support for that supremely
anti-democratic act I think in that era
and with those sorts of languages being
deployed and with the forces that I see
your enlightenment and social democracy
cowed and weak we are in a dangerous
time in our politics and one where I
don't think there is an easy route
through
[Applause]
where is Britton heading Natalie well I
think you've just heard two very
pessimistic accounts of where Britain's
heading I'm gonna fulfill my role that I
often feel on panels whereas I'm going
to be the optimist because where Britain
is headed for is massive change the
status quo is profoundly unstable and
that's really great news it's great news
for the people of Grimsby it's great
news for the people of South Wales it's
great news for the whole country now
what that change will be I very much
hope and and pretty confident that we
will remain as part of the European
Union and that's what I'm working very
hard to achieve however I do not accept
at all people who criticize people who
voted leave in 2016 who suggest that
they didn't know what they were doing or
that they were deluded or misled or
didn't understand people were voting for
change voting to say our current
situation is intolerable and our current
voting system electoral system doesn't
allow us to make change so we're going
to do anything we possibly can to shake
things up for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at AI
TV
you